Rusia rompe unilateralmente el acuerdo
para exportar granos desde puertos
ucranianos el detonante fue un presunto
ataque del ejército de kiev a la flota
rusa de barcos en el mar Negro en
sebastopol la urbe más grande de crimea
la Península anexada unilateralmente a
la federación en 2014 mientras Ucrania
habla de chantaje y ataques terroristas
inventados
Moscú sostiene que la ofensiva por mar
se produjo con la ayuda de la
inteligencia británica dado el acto
terrorista del 29 de octubre llevado a
cabo por el régimen de kiev con la
participación de especialistas
británicos contra barcos de la flota del
mar Negro y barco civiles involucrados
en garantizar la seguridad del corredor
de granos la parte rusa suspende su
participación en la implementación de
acuerdos sobre la exportación de
productos agrícolas desde Puerto
ucranianos el acuerdo para la
exportación de insumos agrícolas se
firmó el pasado 22 de Julio entre las
partes con la mediación de Naciones
Unidas y Turquía el objetivo era
desbloquear más de 22 millones de
toneladas de grano que estaban
paralizados en Puerto sucranianos desde
el inicio de la invasión un cuya
vigencia se extendía hasta el 19 de
noviembre pero que la ONU se mostraba
optimista para reeditar para evitar una
crisis alimentaria global tras la
decisión Del kremlin el ministro de
exteriores de Ucrania llamó a la
comunidad internacional a presionar al
gobierno ruso hemos advertido sobre los
planes de Rusia para arruinar la
iniciativa de granos del mar Negro ahora
Moscú utiliza el pretexto falso para
bloquear el corredor de cereales que
garantiza la seguridad alimentaria de
millones de personas hago un llamado a
todos los estados para que exijan a
Rusia que detenga sus jueguecitos con el
hambre y vuelva a comprometerse con sus
obligaciones la iniciativa de granos del
mar Negro ahora bajo interrogante ha
facilitado la exportación de 9 millones
de toneladas de cereales y ha salvado de
la pobreza extrema a 100 millones de
personas